Will Ferrell's new movie the house is in
theaters near you on Friday and we'll
back here on the show how are you will
hey rich I'm great
we still have those compasses here would
you want to have them with you when you
want citrate wasn't that great birthday
gift oh my gosh I'm still talking about
it today is my birthday over the weekend
and I'm still talking about it today
well you know and the wife and and you
know what sometimes when I do feel lost
inside inside I'm not just talking about
GPS or actual Geographic loss but mostly
loss yes I I sometimes look at the look
at the keychain and I and then I find
myself
I'll be very honest because you feel
even more lost in that it helps you it
helps you write y'all sure there's no
question about it so I figured I'd bring
it up to you here when you called into
the show how you been
how's life good I have been good um yeah
everything's great
I mean we're all still talking about the
NHL draft right we're just buzzing about
that yeah we're on it
where were you outrage Heiser then I
love your coverage overall coverage it's
been incredible is there any particular
move that outraged you will you want to
get tested we're just I didn't
understand the five-team deal between
Toronto national Columbus Vancouver and
Florida there was mine
35 players traded hands and then they
player to be named later it was renamed
oh yeah what's it years from now we'll
see how that all plays out so I know
you're a method actor how did you
prepare for the house will did you go to
Vegas did you find a actual casino in
somebody's basement how did you prepare
for this I built it well first of all
does a basement hmm and then I built a
casino
I been to Vegas you know number of times
so I have you know I have enough
experience which is your game like which
which casino game are you actually good
at I love pie gal I'm all over it
yeah I actually teach there I'm rich I'm
surprised you haven't been to my PI got
sent up seminar I think I have I didn't
know that please let me know how do I
see weeks every August added [ __ ] oh
yeah that's training camp season man
okay it's preseason football so that's
why I am well I'll say blackjack and I I
uh I kind of learned the basic
fundamentals of craps I'm not a very
adventurous craps player but I kind of
just yeah hang out yeah I learned craps
uh the hard way will and and you know
I'm not talking about like alleyways or
anything like that but uh that you're
not supposed to walk up to the table in
the middle of something that's right and
stand next to the guy who's actually
shooting the dice right because then I
might blame for any bad juju that's
progress hazel so much superstition and
um I didn't you also not supposed to
grab anything on the table
anytime I realize that chips what else
do I mean with anything that dies uh the
stick man's arm yeah you know all right
I'm with you on that front are you um
are you paying attention to Dodger
season at all I know because I know
you're in the middle of Kenneth Walters
are you focused on anything I was at I
was actually at the game Thursday night
okay so that you're definitely following
it what yeah and they are they I mean
I'm a little worried about Seager being
out here but um and Adrian Gonzalez's is
that you knocked up a little bit but uh
but yeah they're they're they're they
seem to be kind of covering all the
bases with all this depth that they have
did you hear that Cody Bellinger in an
interview on ESPN did not know Jerry
Seinfeld was did you hear about yes Wow
he didn't know at all fact and and I
this is not I'm not doing a bit here two
to three weeks ago I was at a Dodger
game and ran into Jerry Seinfeld
so here he was watching Bellinger
Bellinger kid
builder has no idea who he was yeah it's
that kind of freaks me out yeah you know
I mean well I know you know in the day
and age where people think John Madden
is a video game impresario have no idea
about that sort of business you know one
knows who Tiki Barber is what world are
we listening in essentially is whatever
well yeah it's for that's the end of
Western civilization Will Ferrel joining
us here the house in theaters near you
on Friday June 30th I loved your USC
speech will oh thank you congratulations
now have you done that before decision I
spoke down the commencement ice anywhere
yet I spoke to a group of graduating
Michigan athletes the athletic
department decided to give out
interestingly enough they couldn't give
out you know obviously diplomas because
you don't go to high school for that
they did and I'm not saying this just
because of the way we start our
interview they did give out compasses to
the class they were not land of the lost
keychain compasses oh but baby they give
out compasses and they had the longitude
and latitude frozen to Ann Arbor so they
can always find their way home got it
and I gave that commencement address I
never crossed my aunt my mind though to
sing Whitney Houston to them will like
you well yeah I was uh I was writing my
speech and you know as it goes with
using your computer you you write for
ten minutes and then then you dedicate
forty minutes to just watching stuff on
YouTube and somehow I stumbled across uh
the Whitney Houston video from The
Bodyguard and shot oh that's gonna
that's how I'm going to end my speech I
don't know it won't make I don't know
I'll have to try to make make it make
sense I just know my ending now yeah I
unfortunately that eclipsed if I'm not
mistaken your falsetto singing of the
Star Trek theme as well right I went to
falsettos that that was a mistake
correct
hindsight I would have maybe taken out
the star
tract and just ended with the Whitney
but that would normally have stood on
its own right okay it got it got
overshadowed now but in all seriousness
when you sit down and you're next and
you look over to your right or your left
and you see serious academics yeah on
the stage after you do that do you what
were the glances like that you exchanged
with them at that moment will you know
at that point after delivering that
speech and ending with Whitney Houston I
just sat in my chair and I looked
straight ahead
I didn't look left or right for a fear
of that's wicked that's wise it's very
wise that you would do it because at
that point if there's nothing you can do
and if they hate me for it it's too late
and so I'll just look straight ahead oh
my gosh yeah that's so funny because I I
wouldn't I would do this I would not be
able to look left or right for fear of
just some actual doctor staring a hole
through me
and there was there was one of the vice
presidents one of the deans who sat next
see who was very nice it was like I just
sat down before you could say I said
well that just happened and he's an oil
great job crazy oh you nailed it
thank you no well because you want you
you did nail it
I mean seriously in terms of just the
actual singing I mean you you went key
change in everything it's a hard song to
sing it is that's that's out there man I
totally agree it is not easy well good
for you
I would give I would never I would never
been able to I would never have been
able to pull that off ever in a million
so what am I figured I figured they they
they were expecting probably something
bizarre and riots what I delivered so
now how is life as dr. ferral I mean as
it changed walking around are you
different now reached it's you know it's
pretty normal I mean I'm about to go
into surgery after I finish this call
I'm not going to do anything I'm just
going to do okay that's why this
I can walk into any video any outpatient
clinic I want to and just observe yeah
good for you well seriously you're just
all rent payers in your world here I had
Danny Trejo in studio the other day yeah
how did and and we talked about
anchorman okay with with with Danny how
did you get him involved with that I
think you know he uh it was fun talking
to him yeah I I believe that was just a
brilliant mind of one mr. Adam okay your
guy okay
yeah who just thought what if we got
Danny Trejo to play the bartender you
didn't think I'd ask you'd be asked to
Danny Trejo question during this
interview digit you'd that's all I did
but have you seen the Danny Trejo coffee
and doughnuts place on the corner I have
seen it I have Melrose oh my god you put
partaken I have as a matter of fact he
brought some here whoa and it was next
level and then the best part about it
though is when it was over you know when
the interview was over and we were
taking photographs in front of the desk
here in our studio will his friend said
can I take a picture on Danny's phone
luxury and he held up the cell phone and
there was a picture of a white kitty cat
on it and I looked at Danny and I'm like
really I mean for real it was the last
thing I could he had Saint kitty on it
was like it was dress that was like his
little screensaver on his phone no I was
like the the phone protector the cover
on his phone right the case protector
yeah was a little white dick kidding
that was a little that was a curveball
thrown at him right there and that way
you know well I think with every uh with
every ten dozen doughnuts you buy it
Danny Trejo you get a white kid get it
that's one of their it is that hey
they're trademarks will thank you for
calling in today would love to have you
back in studio next time and congrats in
advance on the house I look forward to
seeing it I look forward to seeing it
always a pleasure
yes and congrats again on that USC
speech that was a there was a tour
force I really appreciate it you bet
that's dr. Will Ferrel here on the
Rajasa
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on radio stations across the
country
and audience isn't it amazing you can
download an app with your thumbprint you
should download our app with your
thumbprint